try to play it away from Conor
Clifton the former Boston Bruin
a stall with it he'll be relieved
of the puck Buffalo going the other
way Skinner to Thompson it's treed right
in and r with a huge save a very strong
start Clifton the defenseman jumps in you have
a hooking penalty the captain in the process
he Thompson can wire the puck he has range like
any it's Rod brinmore who said he has some Mario
worked AC cross PKA he'll get it back from power
side of the net Theo out in front for cribs and
oh my goodness ATI Mercy his best save of the
year no doubt about it really good job on the
goal line from aoso turning and finding the lane
for the great a chance and he bites on the Move
in the backand but the glove is the bayth of
all Bays you know he told me because he went
back to his old equipment I spoke to him this
morning his tuck plays it for Skinner off the
boards doen he goes across the ice for Thompson
his cross ice pass intercepted by slaven and now
he Springs in on go drwan lcan with his first
big save of the game all chances in this game
and a short-handed chance for Jack Drury but
Lucan in had the answer two big redwoods up
top for the Buffalo Sabers on their penalty kill
is see there green when he gets a stick in the
passing Lane Buffalo chasing after it trying to
clear k Ste in at the point D'Angelo shoots he
scores oh the power play Tony D'Angelo's
first of the year puts the canes up one-
nothing well you start with an entry on the
power play you have to all work the penalty
killers and get possession before position and
that's exactly what happened all three forwards
were below the goal line and D'Angelo through
a maze of bodies when far post a beautiful
sounding ping in in big moment for D'Angelo
now Terra Biden trying to make a second as
he's taken down crashing towards the net Puck
still loose smov tried to pick it up but Eric
Johnson was behind him and yeah he was thinking
about the lacrosse move now fetch nikov gets it
back go Ki up Top orlock tering Shot Lucan gets
a piece now Shay way up from his defensive spot
the speet nikov he goes back up top orlock
side of the net looking for Terin rebounds
there for spech nikov luk gets a piece get it
to tuck Thompson his return feed interrupted
martinook could have a break as Buffalo had a
bat change maruk shot right off save made by
Luc Carolina carrying the puck into the Buffalo
Zone whipped across for n back out in front and
just be failing to pull the trigger goami shoves
one into the slot Jarvis don't play it off the
inboards we Yoki haru's there now tuck he'll send
it across and Peta just out of the box he's taken
down to the ice and then he'll try to play it
to the slot tied out front and they'll score
oh Alex tuck with the turnover and stayed with
it and Buffalo's tied it at one chadfield uses
it skating ability and fronts the Sabers Crest
makes a good play but Buffalo sticks with it
my gosh that is some kind of play by Peta out
of the box after chadfield legally uses his
physicality to get it to the front of the net
Jarvis wasn't as hard on the puck as obviously
he should have been ronto makes one save and
talk the former Vegas gold night scores on the
second one Caroline zone now Buffalo will turn
it right back up Tuck the goal scorer on the
back end cuts out in front and Ron got in front
of that mle stat to Skinner Skinner sharp angle
that rang the post aunti Ron has been good
as Alex tuck was looking for the lead and R
denies now spech nikov towards the shoulder low
Drive misses Cami tries he'll shovel one out in
front but a penalty coming up as Carolina's
pressured p in the corner you go Haru trying
to play it away from martinook Good Work by
martinook out in front and foston stall out
there and Lucan has to make a save played up
the boards Clifton was way up now stall he's
got martinook coming with him sends it in from
martinook and Lucan gets across to make the sa
the gear that they have been trying to locate
sauce from Jordan Stall Landing right on the
tape of marook really worked around D'Angelo tries
to play that to the point buffo can get two-on one
if they hurry it's Genson and aoso aoso right on
R gets across just over the blue line from gens
since two he's on the backand so the shot's
not a threat back for JIS Seth Jarvis dancing
with it trying to go around KBS he comes out in
front little sweep shot by Drury LC makes the
save terrain side of the net for Jarvis back
up top NIS is laying out in front lcan makes
the save with Jarvis on the doorstep and
then lcan will hang on that was a very
deceptive pass from terrifying it allowing
anxious to get he'll find Shay Shay that's
deflected he's in front's Yoki Haru Carolina
with gate Great pressure and it's NIS drop it
chance across the score Brady Shay got to the
quiet spot and he this building Get Loud 21
Carolina combination of speed moving your
feet like nous and then speed moving the
puck orlof no doubt having his best game as
a hurricane the punk bake after NES gets to
the middle goes to Shay excuse me goes to
AO AO sees a a pinching Brady Shay on his
offside puts it right in the Wheelhouse both
defenseman factor in over the game blue lineing
comes in Buffalo has to tag up Dalene with it
dine play it off the boards to himself and he
score a surprise move caught everybody as Rasmus
Dalene passed to himself and the Sabers defenseman
has tied this at two on the power play what a shot
Thompson gets it into Dalene coming underneath
with speed so he backs off the hurricanes with
that speed the Thompson creates indirect it to
himself Puck was on edge he it's almost like
he slinged it I wonder if do man on man that
requires adjustment now a chance for a break Rona
comes all the way out the pl away from Mil and it
runs Mercy gets across he's still got to get to
the blue paint the Kane somehow survived that and
r in the middle of it all every period has made a
huge save here he comes out on Casey middle stat
and then he finds a way selling out to make a
save that plays out he normally usually finds
a way to work that something happens now Burns
works one out front chance put on by martinook
and LC in with two big saves setting this across
for slaven here comes slaven into the Buffalo Zone
he'll go to to the front of the net and Lucan
uses his stick in Middle stot got it enough to
bother him back off power now he'll hand it to
AO AO turning at the Circle wrapping it to Shay
Shay NIS leaves it for AO they're running the
weave AO NES he does it again game [Music] over
[Applause] while fatigue became a factor
for buffalo in three on three speed went
three or four levels up as we go around the
clock and around the clock until eventually
AO pays back the favor of Saturday night
against the Islanders where Nate just went
to him this time he goes right back to Nate
just no look past flat in overtime [Applause]